the most legendary sword both in fiction
and in real world history is also one of
the most misunderstood armaments of our
time
i am of course talking about the katana
a sword that is an iconic part of
japanese culture and history
romanticized as connected spiritually
with its wielder and full of
misconceptions when it comes to its
appearance in cinema
anime and video games on this episode of
loadout we take a look at some of the
misconceptions that surround the
sharpened steel of the samurai
and talk to the royal armouries curator
of oriental collections
natasha bennett so we can better
understand the myths and legends that
surround
the katana
the first thing that anyone thinks about
when it comes to the katana is the
almost absurd level of sharpness that
this sword has
we're often shown it being able to make
clean cuts through anything
and anyone in some cases with such speed
and finesse that the object doesn't fall
apart until many seconds later
i think it's hyped up and oversimplified
quite a lot on certain occasions yes
there's this idea that
a katana can put through anything from a
rock to
a piece of silk thrown into the air we
do have a sword in the armories
collection
that is reputed to have cut through a
block of stone and survived without even
a chip they are lethal cutting weapons
but one of the most common
misconceptions the surround japanese
swords as a whole is that every sword
was a katana
no matter the shape length or use
whereas in reality the katana was just
one
razor sharp part of the samurais or
ashigaru's arsenal
a katana is only one type of sword the
technology and the basic underlying
principles
of construction within japanese swords
as a whole
that doesn't really change over the
course of an entire millennium
within that the swords do develop and
this is all due to the
change in taste and also crucially
alterations in fighting approaches and
the way the battles are conducted
the katana took over from the tachi and
became more popular as the combat was
switching from individual cavalry
skirmishes
to close up battles on foot with
multiple opponents
before the mongol invasions the sword
tended
on the whole to be a secondary weapon
most combat was undertaken on
an individual basis at least in the
first instance
once the mongolian invasion happened the
japanese had quite a nasty shock because
the mongols didn't adhere to any of
these fighting tactics
they fought in large groups mostly on
foot
they used short very very powerful bows
and very importantly they had spears the
japanese
forces learnt from this the ashigaru the
foot soldiers
they needed a sword that was shorter
easier to wield on foot so as a result
of all these factors the katana
developed into this ideal sword
the quicker draw of the sword was well
suited to the more intimate
confrontations
where victory was decided by speed and
reaction time the new style of sword
also meant that swordsmen could in
theory
draw their blade and strike the enemy
with one fluid motion
as the sharpened edge of the blade was
worn facing up whereas previously the
tachy had been worn with the blade
facing down
swords were also not the first weapon to
be called upon in a battle
instead samara and ashigara would use
yumi bows spears and glaives
before engaging one on one with their
sidearm swords shouting challenges to
their opponents
the element of shouting challenges and
reciting exploits of your bloodline is
something we've seen a lot of in pop
culture
and even as a gameplay mechanic that is
represented in the ghost of tsushima
which allows you to challenge group of
mongols or straw hat ronin as you
approach the field of battle
an aspect that other games in the genre
also touch upon
this is one of the many elements that
feeds into the image of honorable jewels
using the katana
and japanese sword fighting in general
the whole reasoning behind
engaging in an individual way was to
ensure that you were of a similar
social strata to your opponent
if they were below you they weren't
worthy of
fighting the mongols just completely
flawed them they just weren't ready
to take on an enemy that had a very
utilitarian shall we say approach
to fighting and and they weren't used to
these large bodies of men
who were able to keep their horses at
bay within
that context fighting one-on-one with
the sword will have had
similar connotations another element
that surrounds the discussion of the
katana is its metallurgical makeup
debate old and new have picked european
swords against asian weapons
arguments often encompass the pros and
cons of differing forging techniques as
well as claims that japan had
worse iron in relation to the rest of
the world and are often invoked when the
katana is compared to other swords from
across the world
the steel is extracted from an iron ore
that's kind of sluiced out of riverbeds
the raw metal that comes out of that is
very high quality
this was then smelted to produce the
swordsmith's main
starting material which is known as
tamahagany the pieces of tamahagany
would
be piled on an iron plate wrapped in wet
paper
coated in a kind of slurry and then
heated to welding temperature
the smith is aided in hammering out this
block
of metal which then famously is folded
welded and then re-hammered usually
about 15 to 20 times the effect of this
is to remove
kind of the impurities in the metal the
outcome
is to make sure the finished saw blade
has
a section of steel that is high carbon
forming
the cutting edge and the point and then
steel that is
low carbon and softer forming the main
body of the blade
the blades hammered out into the shape
with regular reheating to allow it to be
worked
the next famous stage is that it's
coated in clay the areas of the blade
that are intended to be kept soft they
have a thicker coating of clay
and the the cutting edge has a much
thinner coating and the result of this
is that when the blade is then reheated
and it's then quenched very quickly in a
horizontal bath
of of water the cutting edge cools much
faster because it's got this thinner
coating of clay
it contracts to become very very hard
whereas the
softer area cools more slowly so it
remains
relatively flexible and durable after
this you've got that
instantly recognizable curved blade and
this would then be
polished it's a really painstaking
process
and it reveals the the beautiful grain
in the steel that comes about
as part of the manufacturing process
both due to the creation and care that
these blades have received during the
centuries that they've been forged
katanas from the feudal period of japan
are still lethal cutting weapons years
later
while european swords were found in
battlefields or discarded in bogs and
mud
many of the most legendary japanese
swords were handed down from generation
to generation and almost always
received an unprecedented level of care
and attention this level of care means
we can still see the lethality of blades
that were hammered and folded
so long ago one of the reasons the
katana has such a legendary status and
has also received such a high level of
care and safekeeping
was that the sword was also a status
symbol with long periods of japanese
history where only the ruling samurai
class
were able to proudly wear longswords one
of these periods was during the rule of
tatayami hideyoshi who called a great
sword hunt in 1588
and forbade any of the japanese
peasantry to own or wear a weapon
the famous samurai however were exempt
from this ruling
one of the reasons that the sword is so
legendary
is that it was intrinsic to the identity
and the status of samurai it was
absolutely fundamental to
their identity and their position and
the recognition
of their role in society a good sword
is very much a status symbol so if you
can afford it and if your
ranking is senior enough then yes you
would have a good quality
blade if you hadn't inherited one
already that was centuries old by that
point
swordsmiths were and still are regarded
as artists
one of the most famous being goro nyodo
masamune who died in 1343 but is still
regarded as japan's greatest swordsmith
one of his most famous blades is the
honjo masamune which represented the
tokugawa shogunate
during most of the ido period and was
passed from shogun to shogun as rulers
came and went
however it has unfortunately been
missing since the american occupation of
japan
the production of japanese swords was
banned by us forces
and due to this the apparent last
sighting of this legendary sword was at
a police station
in december 1945. the hunt for this
sword
still continues to this day while the
masamune is regarded as a lost national
treasure
there are also wilder stories that
surround a number of swords with them
often being called cursed
or bloodthirsty considering that during
the sengoku period
widespread lawlessness led to samurai
committing violence and murder against
the civilian populace
even using random unarmed civilians to
test out the sharpness of their swords
a practice known as goody or crossroads
killing
this is certainly odds with the ideal of
an honorable samurai
that we see in much modern media within
japan
swords are greatly admired as art
objects they
command a great deal of respect um for
the exquisite craftsmanship that they
still display
and the massive cultural significance
that they embody
it even goes as far as a number of
living swordsmiths currently practicing
swordsmiths are regarded as living
national treasures due to the vital role
that they're perceived as playing
in preserving the cultural heritage of
japan the fact that the japanese sword
is so popular and it's so
instantly recognized shows that there's
this enduring appeal on multiple levels
so it's brought in in many many
different ways
and as a result the japanese sword has
remained very very relevant
but sometimes i think it could come
across as quite sensationalized and i
think ultimately that
sometimes it risks diminishing the quite
nuanced role
of of the japanese sword but both has a
historical weapon
and is a really important cultural
symbol
with this reputation and reverence in
mind it only makes sense that in the
realms of pop culture they exist on such
a huge spectrum
from the reserve depictions in classic
kurosawa films to the over-the-top
sword clashes of anime to games like neo
sakura
and ghost of tsushima which all run the
gamut ghost of tsushima is an
interesting one
as it aims to pay homage to aspects of
japanese culture of the time
but while it takes some liberties with
its setting its themes can also be
interpreted as being emblematic to how
the samurai changed during the era
and especially how the katana was
respected and wielded the weapons and
armor of the samurai class were
incredibly respected by their wielders
but also their families and clans and
this respect carries over in some of the
media we see today
as well as being echoed in real life the
katana on japanese swords in general
loom pretty large in
the realms of popular culture the most
popular idea that you probably hear
people quoting is that the sword
the japanese sword is the song of the
samurai they're passed down through
generation after generation of a family
uh or they're giving to shrines for safe
keeping so they're still pristine
and magnificent um at the current time
so
that their reputation is kind of
condensed as a result of that
popularly regarded as the best cutting
weapon ever the most perfectly formed
cutting weapon ever
but there's accounts of skilled samurai
cleaving opponents heads into through a
helmet
these weapons were absolutely lethal
particularly if
they were in the hands of trained
swordsmen now i'll be the first to admit
that the process of interviewing and
researching for this episode of loadout
challenged a lot of what i thought i
knew about the katana
there were things about its strengths
and weaknesses forging techniques and
usage
that i thought i knew but there was also
so much more that i learned along the
way
and i hope that goes for you too
watching at home but does this sword of
such legendary repute deserve the
incredible regard that it still has
today
do movies anime and games pay a
respectful homage
and how much of it is exaggerated even
though there are so many legends and
exaggerated stories a lot of those
probably based in reality
to some extent i don't think there's
smoke without a fire
where the japanese sword's concerned
and the katana is part of that
if you look at the vast number of
exquisite
examples that are preserved in shrines
and
temples and museums and private
collections in japan and across the rest
of the world
they're still absolutely incredible
objects to look at
and to have something that pristine that
has lasted in peak condition
from when it was first made in the 11th
12th 13th 14th centuries
it demonstrates that these swords show
an absolute pinnacle of craftsmanship
that was so
enduring it shows the respect that
they've been
held in within their society they're
revered
now they're an iconic and instantly
recognizable motif of popular culture
and i think that's happened for a very
good reason there's a lot of foundation
there
to suggest that its image and reputation
is highly justified so that about does
it for this slice of content
but i want to know if what you heard
here today taught you anything new
or challenged any of the beliefs that
you previously held about the katana
we'll have a future video looking at the
katana's use in games coming very soon
but i don't want to give too much away
about that just yet and until next time
thank you so much for watching like the
video if indeed you did
and if you want to talk about the
coolest swords in our pop culture you
can hit me up on twitter
at a regular dave or leave your thoughts
in the comments section down below
and until next time thank you so much
for watching